any other questions um i mean everything
sonic rider yes
listen i know this is going to get flat
right i'm surprised this wasn't the
immediate thing that i was giving flag
for right
right i'm just shocked there's a sonic
game honestly like
i didn't give you flack because i was
actually really close to putting sonic
adventure 2 on my
no sonic battle adventure 2 yeah yeah
that was that was
that easily could have been on here
running around at the speed of sound
just for like me like
me like giving like my chows like
steroids oh my god
[ __ ] in here drag him
yeah i mean like sonic riders was like
the one game that
because it came with my gamecube right
so when i bought the gamecube it was
when it was
already dying and they were just
literally trying to sell it with
anything so i got like um
a bunch of free games with my gamecube
for like very cheap
and sonic riders was the one that i
hated most that came with this game
right i was like
i was like these controls suck dick it
is one of the most jank sonic it's like
so [ __ ] jank right
and like the the learning curve for this
game the mechanics seemed completely
like overkill
like a kids game yeah but then after
like i actually sat down
and like just for like 20 hours didn't
understand the game and like eventually
understood what was happening
this game felt so [ __ ] clean like it
felt so good
i felt that way with uh kirby's air ride
as well because right
for the first like 10 hours i was like
wait it's not just a racing game yeah
what the [ __ ] is this i have to like
earn my ride and then go into
what the right right because there was
like this like glide mechanic where you
had to like jump in the other person's
like
trail yeah it was completely jank and it
would like throw you out and stuff and
it was
so jang but it was like probably the one
game where
my impressions on it completely 180
after i like actually put time into it
right i got good at it and i was like
wait this is a [ __ ] clean game
and i played it so goddamn much i played
this game so
i was glad to know that i'm not the only
one who has like a 3d sonic game as like
a guilty pleasure game
dude yeah it was like for me it was
sonic heroes
i could have personally yeah and i
didn't put in my three by three just
because like if i did
i know people will be like you put a 3d
sonic kick
dude i could i could
like fond memories of any 2d sonic games
but it's the 3d sonic games
they have fun i remember i tried it look
because it's
there's one reason because i was a
nintendo kid through and through so
sonic wasn't available till the gamecube
okay
that's why exactly that's why listen
sonic right this is a good game
if you if you learn listen like if you
watch people play it for the first time
they'll be like this is [ __ ] garbage
yeah this is the worst game ever
but then if you see someone who's good
at it you're like damn that looks
[ __ ] good
no legit it's a good game no it is a
good game i played it
that's why i'm glad to know that like
i'm not the only one who's like you know
what
there are good sonic games sonic heroes
if i replayed it probably jank
as [ __ ] oh yeah i probably hate the [ __ ]
out of it i'm like i remember that
casino level i [ __ ] hated
in that game but i enjoyed sonic and i
remember you just keep dying randomly
from stuff in there yeah it was it was
one of the most i don't think it was a
[ __ ] game yeah i don't think i've played
sonic heroes but i've definitely played
some 3d sonic games and i've actually
enjoyed most of them
it's it's [ __ ] i mean i mean i mean
black ops is self-explanatory
black ops 2 that is i think even though
i played like
i'll tell you the difference there's a
big there's a massive difference okay
okay
okay there's you know as if any you know
which one's the one where it literally
starts off with the airport getting shot
up
that's modern inside that's my extent
of knowledge of course that came out
that was such a big deal like oh yeah it
was a huge
deal my mom like she'd already bought me
the game and then she was like
connor i've heard about this thing in
this game where you kill a bunch of
people in an airport
i didn't buy you that game did i and i
was like no no no
no
2 is the one that i probably played the
most modern warfare 3 is one where i won
a bunch of
free [ __ ] yeah and then black ops 2 was
probably the one i had most fun with and
that i played competitively like in
teams and stuff and i really enjoyed
yeah it was so fun it was so clean yeah
that game they like optimized it it was
like the best card 100 hands down
the maps were the best the multiplayer
had like a good rank system which they'd
never had before
i don't think they ever put back in like
it was legit good it was such a it was
just a [ __ ] great game
fantastic [ __ ] game anyone who likes
card will tell you that black ops 2 is
the best game yeah that's that's
what i hear most of the time it's like
it's either black ops 2 or modern
warfare you're like this is all noise to
me
is is this how it feels when we talk
about music
probably i'm i'm like i'm like cool oh
yeah
like it's has it got the pp the most
balanced you know it's just a great game
it's just the game and i put way too
many hours and it's what got me into
like competitive gaming and i like
really
that was like the first esports i
started watching oh yeah yeah it had
like a really good tournament
okay um but then all the [ __ ] pro
players like weird as [ __ ] at that time
they were just like yeah it was weird it
was very strange